[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
AKA grace on hilberg the first we have
Francia ray sia I can't pronounce her
name Francia like the box wine but
better with us on this episode of not
too deep and she is such a treat she's
on groan --is-- she's amazing she is
grown ish she started dating her
boyfriend ungrown - we talk about love
relationship the industry and just how
she you know has worked with everyone
under the Sun it turns out name anyone
in Hollywood and she has a surprising
story about somehow working with them
she's also worked with my favorite one
of my favorite wrestlers the Miz and
it's a very hilarious tale so enjoy this
episode of not too deep with Francia
[Music]
okay I've done some research and you
were in a Christmas movie with the Miz I
was I'm a big wrestling fan I went to
Wrestlemania for the last three years so
am i but I got to had to miss it this
last [ __ ] yeah wait did you go last year
yeah in New Orleans
yeah yeah I was there oh man if you saw
someone stumblin that was me probably I
was too busy screaming yeah okay yeah
talk to me about this have you always
been a wrestling fan yeah it started
when I was little and I think it was
third or fourth grade I had a crush on a
boy uh-huh
all he talked about was wrestling I was
like yeah me too totally like that at
the time was dubbed WF yeah
no that's I used to watch it with my
brothers growing up and so that was my
point of reference and then when it's
such a over W dip like I fell off for
years only in the last like four years
have I gotten more into it again well
same I fell off four years and then I
got the movie with my they called and I
said hey we would love for you to be a
part of it was like my only condition is
can I go to Wrestlemania know what this
script was I had no idea what I was
doing I don't have to be this badass
bounty hunter but I it was like I just
want to go to Wrestlemania
exactly so got to do the movie and yeah
I go to Wrestlemania pretty much every
year I just couldn't this last
this year I don't know why do you have a
favorite wrestler
it's tough cuz I've gotten to meet a lot
of them yeah you know and if mike hears
me and I don't say I was just at his
gender-reveal party I really yeah oh
that's incredibly I was fun I remember
yeah when we my friends and I went to
like Monday Night Raw like at the
Staples Center a couple years ago that's
how he like got back into it and I
remember seeing the myth of being like
wait a minute I remember him on real
real-world doing this character in the
house and everyone thought he was crazy
yeah crazy it's not tiring he manifested
this career for himself
it was super inspired so manifestation
is so real yes because of that I was so
nervous to work with him because I had
also watched the real world I was like
he's an [ __ ]
he's a jerk I really rooted for him in
choral together I didn't know but what
was your what ended up being your first
impression of him on set I was shocked
because he's the nicest human you will
ever meet in your life like he's amazing
I agree don't worry I don't like miz
yeah much but that's how you know he's
doing a good job acting he's amazing at
it and he definitely turns it on when
the cameras are rolling cuz we're I mean
we were at our chairs just having a
normal casual conversation about family
and stuff uh-huh and then EPK came over
to film and he just turned it on and I
literally was like nah I don't know who
you are right now but I don't like you
yeah all of a sudden oh my god this is a
dr. Jekyll or Hyde situation going on
right now are you going to raw when it's
in a couple weeks I I mean I went to
Wrestlemania I always want to go it's
just like scheduling stuff but I've also
kind of like fallen off from Russell I
mean going into this Wrestlemania I felt
like the least prepared yeah like I
hadn't kept up with all the storylines
understand and but it was really cool to
see like this is the first time that the
females were like the big ticket but
also you know those events are like
10,000 hours long
yeah so by the time you get to the final
like match which is like the headliner
you're like I got I would like to leave
now I am very exhausted yeah it's all so
credibly are you there for the pre-show
we they cuz we're they want like social
media influencers to like come and be
like those around it and that sort of
thing so we tried to get there as like
decent time as we could to run this
marathon of this event but we didn't see
the full pre-show okay have you thought
of your wrestling persona I haven't I
haven't figured it out yet okay so every
time I go on the red carpet my name is
Delilah rose because that's the only way
I can channel this whatever happens on
there
wait this is how you prepare to do red
carpet yes red carpet or when I have to
host anything or whatever like I have to
channel Delilah Rose which I loved Xena
the warrior princess showing up like
it's a little bit of her but I call her
Delilah yeah ours name is Xena and so I
just really I named everything so I
literally have to channel her so I feel
like it would be Delilah Rose Wow that's
a great name yeah that sounds like you
like almost like either a porn star or
like an American Gladiator well it's
kind of what wrestlers are on I took a
pole class you need a stripper name of
like so that's where Delilah Rose
happened that's incredible you know what
I might have to change it on my post
mates now my name is melody janitor on
all the apps that are in my neighborhood
that's Fantan sir the door I make my
boyfriend do it and one time oh that's
so funny yeah you just did the Golden
Globes red carpet right yeah no I've
only been on a handful of red carpets in
there incredibly stressful to me and
overwhelming because there's just so
much frenzied energy going on and
there's just like everyone has different
missions going on how was that for you
it was a different type of frenzy crazy
I have so much respect for hosts yeah I
didn't know people were in their ear
telling them what to do like earpiece
yeah I had no idea I was a nervous wreck
and I didn't know how to channel Delilah
in that environment because Delilah was
confused all you to do is smile
well I read a teleprompter that's like
this big and I need glasses but am I
gonna have glasses and then I you know
had people my ear like Oh so-and-so just
posted this on Instagram ask this and
like oh well I didn't hear the last part
why
and then you look crazy because you're
trying to hear what's in your the voice
is in your head literally the voices in
your head as Charlize Theron is giving
an answer and I'm just staring at her
beautiful precious skin like I love you
and I'm trying not to act like it right
now I don't know how to not look like a
creep right now
yeah those environments are so chaotic
it's nuts yeah would you do it again I
would definitely do it again really for
sure it's it's a lot of fun it was
interesting being on that side and I
think it's just cuz I want to be at the
parties yeah yeah yeah yeah but I would
do it again have you had any super
memorable experiences at after parties
um let's see memorable man more like
fangirl moments oh yeah so many fangirl
moments for sure
not at this after-party specifically but
there's definitely fangirl moments where
I've seen like members from NSYNC yeah I
actually went to Nick Carter's wedding
ah yeah what okay you have so many just
casual tidbits about yourself realizing
until we're talking about it right now
it's like well I'm kind of lived a life
how did that come about my really good
friend and also real estate agent is his
real estate agent and she was like I
need a plus-one and I know you're really
good around those environments
I was like yeah for sure and I went and
all the Backstreet Boys was there and I
was like really trying to keep my cool I
saw them in Vegas and I lost my [ __ ]
mind yeah I didn't I knew how it's gonna
have a great time I would think I was
more of an instinct girl growing up so I
was like this will still be really fun
and I like couldn't contain myself
I've lost my [ __ ] I became like the
biggest fan in the universe unbeknownst
to me and I just like was screaming and
crying and like annoying every lyric
emotional it was emotional yes emotion
somehow I had every lyric registered in
the back of my brain
amazing yeah absolutely what happened oh
how was the party
it was great and Kevin I had a
heart-to-heart about the entertainment
industry I'm getting schooled about the
business right now
he always seems to me like the big
brother that has wisdom yeah I get mean
he's the oldest of all of them right
that's true yeah we had I had posted a
picture as I'm sure it's on my Instagram
I'm like this happened oh that's
incredible yeah okay do speak in like
social media are you into it is it
something you do as like a byproduct of
like working or is it something that you
genuinely enjoy I'm learning to
genuinely enjoy it yeah for a long time
especially when it first started I mean
it didn't exist when I was started in
this industry like back when I was on
secret life the American teenager
Instagram started probably our last
season oh and I didn't know what to post
I remember with Twitter I'm like so I'm
supposed to tell people where I'm at I
don't get it so not so it was work for
me and I'm like okay I gotta figure out
my brand initially and figure out how to
make it all pretty and I feel like my
page is all over the place but I'm
actually finding that the feedback I'm
getting is it's more genuine and I feel
like people actually know me from what
people are telling me I was like oh so
you gotta just yeah and I just have to
keep it up it looks like people can tell
it's you posting yeah it's not like a
team behind you like pretending to be
you yes these things but I'm definitely
conscious like there's things that I
want to post that I don't like for
example my friends and I were watching
The Bachelorette last night and there
were so much I wanted to post but Hanabi
follows me and I'm like this guy's gonna
win but this is how I feel I haven't
watched this season that's this is the
one season that I've fallen off from
because I just got that are so bored
last season
yes I didn't know I was gonna be as
entertained as I am really so I should
pick it up this season
I recommend it cuz I thought I would be
so bored and it's really all my girls
got together we haven't done these the
last few seasons yeah and my boyfriend
but we're getting together drinking wine
yelling like men with sports yeah yeah
but I'm over here be like other girls
like but he's so hot and then fast
forward she's like I take back
everything I'm like I can smell a
douchebag of a pot of the way don't try
don't test me
that's incredible okay I will I mean I
don't really need a reason to get into
it I should already be into it I'm
obsessed with reality television anyway
no it's a lot more entertaining than I
thought I'll tell you that
yeah do you watch any other reality TV
not really I think that's really my only
vice unless is there anything else she
knows me myself other than wrestling
other than wrestling which is the
greatest reality programming of all time
it really is who's your favorite
wrestler oh I love Finn Balor
okay another club but he had he is a
little cut he's a little boring to me
I love Dean Ambrose but now he's retired
no he's not well he's moving to like a
difference he just yeah he W or
something or there's some other Cody
Rhodes yeah started a new wrestling yeah
he just debuted there the other day
apparently there's a lot of people that
are gonna be kind of following suit it's
very scandalous but yeah and yeah I
can't wait to watch it's like its own
reality TV show yeah it's like crazy
right now and apparently someone just
tweeted like kind of promoting it that
kind of think might get people nervous
cool I can't wait to check it out can't
believe I didn't say this I love Jeff
Hardy like that oh yeah the hardy
brothers when I was at WrestleMania two
years ago and they came out on a
retirement there were like grown men
next to me sobbing and I was like this
is incredible I lost it and see I wasn't
even that familiar I like kind of knew
and I was like those men like I they're
sort of familiar to me but I don't know
the gravity of this for everyone else
like I've been in love with Jeff I lost
it I would have been crying with that
that's incredible
is there do you have like people that
you follow on social media on Instagram
that's like your go-to enews enews way
and they're hit stories this is my thing
oh I do click on their stories though
because the commentary afterwards are so
funny oh you mean the comments on there
no like the videos that they post kind
of with their reaction you know what was
it they posted something today and then
Lindsay Lohan from Mean Girls as I
comment afterwards what was it about at
people getting along like it doesn't
matter
I remember what it was something about
Sophia Ricci so it entertains me in the
morning
those are your morning mantras my
morning and whatever my sister sends me
I got sobbing this morning watching
America's Got Talent
we all have those vices online that
really hit us in the field some yeah
okay let's talk about secret life
because I remember watching this show
when it first came out and I was so like
floored by it because I remember seeing
it and being like what is this oh wow
this is serious stuff
this is like a almost like a soap opera
for like high schoolers yeah and the way
cuz I remember Degrassi growing up hmm
what's like at the same vein where it's
like handling a lot really serious but
actual like realistic issues really like
high schoolers are you an OG Jimmy fam
oh oh gee me in the wheelchair I mean
then we'll Chad oh yeah I used to intern
at the N in New York and like one of my
internships I would get sent dailies
from the set and that's how I learned
what Degrassi was cuz I didn't have in
college didn't have a TV so I wasn't
watching anything nor do we have like
that station on like our local access it
was a random station that it aired on it
was not I got obsessed with it because I
was like there's nothing like this from
this age group out how was it working on
secret life were you like did did
everyone understand like that that was
how big it was no really I think it's
still hard for us to understand it yeah
cuz that went for like what five years
or something something like that we
don't even know and it's crazy because
you know it's referred to as like a cult
classic
yeah similar to maybe Saved by the Bell
or something that's what we've heard and
we're like what really yeah that's like
it's so weird I remember with um when I
first auditioned for groan --is-- mm-hmm
yard knew who I was right away but I
thought is cuz we met and like she
played off like we've met before nothing
and now we're second season we're
filming and then all of a sudden Yara
Chloe and Holly were like yo secret life
was my jam and I'm like what
yeah they were like Iago's I was
starstruck when I first saw you watch
they were like yeah we tried to keep it
cool I'm so crazy but no we didn't know
at the time I was 19 when I was filming
it wow did you film here in Los Angeles
yeah I've been very lucky with both
shows we were at the Warner Brothers
ranch cool very cool but we didn't
realize that I mean winning a Teen
Choice Award like five episodes in was
really cool it's nuts yeah cuz there was
just nothing like it I remember being
just so fascinated by it and so it's
like how is there nothing like this and
everything that is sort of like this is
like really cheesy and really sappy and
this feels more realistic to me I guess
the seventh heaven was like the closest
like counterpart well you know it's the
same creator right it's the same guy
female her female rather yeah
did it come on after seven seven he's
already done oh yeah like years later
okay so she was a part of blossom and
seventh heaven and this ah she's had an
itch I know so what's it like working on
grown --is-- now what was that audition
process like it was interesting because
well first of all ha I got the script
and I was in a weird time where I was
like I don't look my age I'm 30 years
old
I mean 31 in July but I look 17 right so
it was a time which like I was getting a
lot of auditions to play my age but I'm
not like I don't look it and you know if
I was going out for stuff that was
younger I was you know look the part but
when producers I guess know how old you
are it kind of confuses them a bit and
they're like I don't know if she can do
this and I didn't at first I was like I
don't know if like can I be on set with
a bunch of young people but it turns out
um they're a lot more mature than you've
ever heard Yara Shahidi speech um yeah
she's the most inspiring like
entrepreneurial person in the world yeah
I wanna be like her when I grow up I'm
like okay I went to college - no yeah
isn't she like doesn't she play like a
million instruments and like is she in
school now in the background yeah yeah
she was doing homework while we're on
set and that's disgusting in between
takes reading she loves to read she
loves history she's teaching me about
the Boston Tea Party on set right just
like did you guys know
and I'm like I'm trying to figure out
these taxes right now so funny yeah how
is set it seems like I mean everyone
seems like they're having a great time
like behind the scenes of it all on
social media it looks like everyone's
genuinely enjoying themselves we are so
close it's not even funny like we're
really good friends we have so much fun
I feel bad sometimes because they call
action and we don't hear it okay so
sometimes some of the stuff you guys see
on TV like before the dialogue starts us
having conversation those are all real
wow we're really laughing we're really
having conversation just goofing around
oh that's very sweet yeah it's awesome
um but like you're I feel like you know
going through all of your social media
you're really active in activism on
especially on Twitter right like I'm
always curious about that for like where
do you find your balance and how much
you dive into being more of an activist
online versus like holding back I guess
I'm still trying to figure that out I
mean there are certain topics that just
pissed me off so much that I just
couldn't yeah stay quiet and I've
learned how important our platform is
and using our voices and speaking for
those that don't know how to speak for
themselves like you know when daca was
first being challenged it was like I
didn't even I wasn't even aware what
really what it was and I had family that
was in danger and I was like what I
don't understand why we're being called
aliens and like were these people that
are just raping the United States like
what's happening and so that really
frustrated me because I'm you know
meeting so many peers that are part of
the program and they're working their
asses off to just live yeah live just
work go to school all of this stuff so I
had to say something because I'm a
daughter of immigrants my mom's from
Mexico my dad's from home do tasks
mm-hmm and they've worked so hard to not
just for themselves but for us my dad
has a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
down the street yeah dad's a major radio
personality man and I'm like and he's
from on dudas he's amazing just came
here and he you know I he did a lot of
philanthropy work you know building
homes and stuff so it really hurt my
feelings more so because we consider
ourselves like family like if you're
from Mexico or just let me know like
week
at you like we're just family yeah so
that that really upset me and then
obviously the whole abortion yeah yeah
I'm so hot and bothering to I think all
of us yeah I mean you cannot tell me
what to do with my body
like obviously you know we all have our
opinions about it but it's it's that
about 25 guys mm-hm telling a woman no
the photos of the men that have it's
infuriating
he makes me throw my laptop out my
window well then I read some quotes
someone posted some quotes from some of
these conservatives saying well if a
woman was being raped her body has the
power to shut it down oh my god so okay
I think they're getting us confused with
like the Avengers sure some of these
women ways yeah yeah and then when it
comes to you know to rape and you know
incest it's just like it's a real thing
like what are you gonna do and now you
know their whole logic to it is we're
just trying to save babies but to me
they're just putting more babies in
danger yeah because there's children
that are being raped and pregnant so
that's that doesn't tell me that yeah
well I think it's really amazing that
you are lending your voice to that
because I think like being on shows like
growing a secret life they're already
really impactful for people and to know
that behind the scenes and off camera
you're just as impacted by the things
that might get brought up on the show is
really I think cool for people to see I
appreciate that thank you and also just
makes you a human being you know like it
makes it more interesting and fun and
exciting to follow you online to know
that like behind the scenes you have
actual opinions and thoughts and it's
not just this glossy magazine cover of
like who you are I'm held back I
appreciate it that's min sparing me to
speak more I just you know I'm at the
age where I will have children soon I
mean I'm I'm in my 30s and I just don't
I'm scared for them to grow up in a
world like this yeah and so if I can do
something about it and unite with other
people so it's not as crazy as it is
right now I'm gonna do it I mean that's
great back in the day we didn't have
Twitter like we do now right and I just
didn't get it and it's that thing you
know with great power comes great
responsibility so it's like use your
power for good yeah exactly
be the change you want to see and all
that
so maybe hey John Instagram all the time
there on e news - yes
okay we're gonna take a quick break when
we get back we have more questions
especially about life size - I'm very
excited to get all this we'll be right
back up or not you're deep are you tired
of unpredictable hair color results say
hello to color & Co personalized hair
color by L'Oreal at color & Co calm you
can get a free instant video
consultation with an expert colorist
from the comfort of your own home your
colorist is there to help you create the
precise color you've been looking for
based on your hair goals and needs
they will prescribe a personalized shade
that's custom blended just for you but
truly personalized hair color goes
beyond a custom shade color and Co also
personalizes your instructions and
application to ensure accurate flawless
results in just a few days you will
receive your personalized color box
along with all the tools and tips you
need to guarantee vibrant soft and shiny
hair with endless hair color
possibilities there's finally one you
can call your own I think this is
fantastic I hate going to salons because
I have a terrible time telling people
exactly how I want my hair color cut and
done and just I don't know how to
describe color you guys know this of me
by now so to be able to get assisted
online from the comfort of my own home
wearing sweatpants and not be judged by
fancy salon folk ah what more could you
ask for take the guesswork out of at
home hair color with color & Co
personalized hair color by L'Oreal use
promo code grace at color and co.com for
$10 off your first personalized color
box
that's color and co.com promo code grace
for $10 off your first personalized
color box
okay let's talk about life size - okay
this is very exciting
Tyra Banks yes back again yeah did you
watch the first one of course yeah I
think every girl grows up but that's
like a Bible in a way right uh so what
was that audition process like and then
hearing that you booked that I didn't
audition they offered it to you yeah
that's incredible it was crazy yeah I
was getting my nails done and I had foil
on my gel oh no and my manager calls and
I get to be in it yeah roll okay hi Ryan
is Lindsay in it oh wow yeah how was
filming it was fun I loved Tyra Banks
yeah what she's I mean a huge
personality obviously I've interacted
with her very minorly on Twitter and it
blew my mind
but what was it like shooting with her
everything you hope she is really so
much more it's amazing and you know she
really takes people under her wing and
she I think she understands the platform
she has yeah so it's not that she hasn't
always turned on but she'll literally
have serious conversations with you and
really give you advice and she wants you
to do well
really yeah cuz that's the vibe she puts
out it's so nice to know that it's not a
false sort of personality and she took
the relationship she and I had very
seriously so when we first met she's
like I feel like we should do dinner or
like go to the spar something do you
like massages I'm like yeah sure and so
then her assistant hit me up and was
like hey are you available for a massage
this time like I'm like gonna go to spa
the tire big and she had me pick her up
so I'm like in a car ride with Tyra
Banks Oh crash I'm in Atlanta in a
rental and don't know what Lana's life
she's a mom precious cargo
yeah and I wasn't gonna say this but I
heard Tyra talk about it in a interview
she's like yeah we went to the spa and I
forgot my bathing suit and we were just
like naked in the hot tub
of real like thrown into a bonding
moment it was really like we were
bonding I was like cool and it was it
was totally fine yeah you know I was
like you know it's I know Tyra Banks
that we're fine it's fine
I'm gonna hot tub with high range right
now that's incredible yeah that was fine
and we just had Girl Talk
got our massages she wasn't ready to
leave she goes do you want to go into
like the quiet room and take a nap I
said mm-hmm not so cool they're like
I've just been naked and slept next to
Tyra Banks for a day yeah and I really
got to know each other and it actually
really helped our relationship all we
were filming oh that's incredible yeah I
was awesome that's super cool so it was
the best experience of my life yeah I
don't know how you top that
I don't either oh that's amazing what do
you do for downtime on sets um I take a
nap oh yeah we are on set 15 like 17
hours a day sometimes really a lot so we
block shoot meaning we're shooting two
episodes at a time okay so from shooting
episode one in the morning we might go
to Episode two at the end in the
afternoon I'm gonna go back and then
table reads so we like to run to our
trailers should take a nap yeah five
minutes or if we don't have time we'll
just be on set talking or find a place
to take a nap we're very tired very
tired what do you do when you're not
shooting while I'm filming well while
I'm filming or one of my height is like
when you're on hiatus when I'm on hiatus
so this season last season I was filming
life-size - mm-hmm this season I had to
take some personal time to figure out a
lot of things like with family and yeah
going to the doctor which you don't have
time to do Oh true or just like general
health stuff yeah so I took this season
and do that and I'm actually currently
training to be a yoga sculpt teacher
really mm-hmm
cool I'm in teacher training right now
what's that like it's fun it's
interesting and it's definitely another
muscle that I never thought I'd tap into
or realize I didn't have I don't have a
script per se to like go true you know
the character on and I'm not that type
of person to be like okay now breathe
and bring your intention into your heart
and your core yeah punch your spine I
don't know it's all this stuff so it's
deaf
another person that I have to figure out
yeah I enjoy and I really do want to
teach that's cool so I'm gonna figure
out how I'll have time to do that yeah
is there a certain number of hours that
you have to do to get certified um so
I'll be able to get certified after
these five weeks I've been doing fine
okay
five weeks Fridays and Saturdays three
and a half hours okay but you have to
complete 50 hours to be a teacher so I
have to do the extension after these
five weeks okay if I want to teach and
then I have to observe classes and take
the boring c1 classes and all this other
stuff I had to take an anatomy class on
Saturday oh really
yeah it's like a lot Wow no I really
like it yeah it sounds intense yeah so
come take my class whenever I find one
I'm so bad at yoga it's in any of those
classes I took a Zumba class once and it
did not go well for me hi but I had fun
so come so I can watch I'll play loud
music so you don't hear me laughing yeah
I literally could not I I knew I didn't
have rhythm and it really really
confirmed it for me immediately so I'm
just laughing in the back of a class
like a Looney tune at myself that's me
realizing I can't do simple grape vines
to save my life that's amazing yeah so
it was um it was an eye-opening
experience um okay which grown is
co-star would you most want to be
handcuffed to where would we be um let's
say you had to do one full normal day
one um wow that's a tough one because it
would be with the girls but I don't know
which girl
a normal day I don't even know what that
looks like
I'm just gonna say I Malika she's very
responsible okay yeah and she'll make
sure that I II shall make sorry exercise
to make sure that we breathe that's good
yeah yeah so she'll be just like an
actual mom yeah she is our mom yeah yeah
great yeah like Trevor will be farting
on say and she'll go Trevor that's not
very nice
apologize yeah you guys have like coups
and spoofs on set do you prank each
other we I don't think we pranked each
other I think Trevor is enough of
entertainment we don't have to do that
yeah just like what are you doing bro
it's really the his farting but just on
purpose or is it just he has a digestive
health issue going on purpose up I can't
hold you guys that's fantastic
it's really great to be in like a
closed-off unventilated room but oh
that's the best is when we have fried
chicken on set and he has a plate of
fried chicken and mac and cheese and all
and greens on his lab they're about to
call action and it puts it on the floor
and he's farting oh man the call action
and we're like we know what you're
farting right now cuz I'm staring at the
plate that is disgusting yeah but also
it's memorable
very he makes an entrance okay your
boyfriend I saw yes you guys have been
together for a year and a half a year
and a half mm-hmm how did you guys meet
well he's on the crew for garnish
oh cool he was first season he was in
the camera department oh sweet and he
said I don't remember this but he said
he made his move after the harassment
meeting an on-set meeting which everyone
was understanding the rules and
regulations and what's appropriate onset
and then he was inspired by that meeting
becoming it I guess yes but it worked
out what was his opening line
do you remember I don't even remember I
was so not in a place to date at that
time yeah hate being this person but
that's gonna happen happen when you
least expect it yeah I wasn't in a place
to date you know I was really nervous
about this job one I was playing 19 and
18 and I was doing comedy for the first
time so I was really in my head oh it
was the first time that you were doing
comedy Wow and my character changed from
my audition like at the table read I
found out and Kenya comes up to me he's
like yeah it's completely different now
like you're gonna have to figure that
out with us Oh easy so I don't know she
is you know so it's been a fun journey
but I didn't even realize he was hitting
on me or anything yeah I had heard from
the hair and makeup department oh you
have a secret admirer and I was like
okay well the please don't tell me what
it is because then I'm gonna get weird
yeah um and I don't want to get weird
uh-huh and I saw an exchange between him
and Yara one time and I was like
like he and he is very attractive but
like I was just so know mm-hmm and then
um he oh he and I were talking randomly
our Kenya Buress was there and then he
walked away and I was like god I can't
make lunch mm-hm so hungry he goes yeah
I don't really eat that much I was like
really he was like yeah I take a nap
during lunch I'm not big on food and
stuff I said you're a weirdo and then it
goes so like do you want to grab lunch
this weekend and I looked at him and I
realized it was him I went yeah I
thought you don't need and then I ran
away a modern romance ya know it started
that's so sweet yeah what was it like
dating while working together well we
didn't tell anyone
yeah so it was fun because it was a
secret but I was so professionals like
you're not allowed in my trailer yeah
you do not come anywhere near my trailer
we are not together on set yeah but I
think people started noticing cuz he
would walk me to my car when I was
leaving and she people noticed that we
talked a lot he's like a big brother to
Yara so he would talk to you are a lot
too but I think people were like oh is
something going on and then I think
right before we wrapped and at this
point he's my boyfriend
yeah our dialect coach was like are you
good is he bothering you and I was like
no why she goes I'm just looking out for
you girl I just if anyone ever makes you
uncomfortable you let me know little did
she know that I'm like no he's just
[Music]
that's fine
how do people just eventually sort of
find out about it oh I posted it let me
rip off the band-aid yeah I'm pretty
much posted it like but it's also nice
I'm sure dating someone that's in this
industry but isn't like doing exactly
what you're doing
but like understands like how like
arduous it can be yes but he's behind
the scenes so a lot of the on-camera
stuff he doesn't get like he didn't
understand why I have to get my makeup
and hair done every time I go out on her
carpet he's like we're going to a movie
I said yes but it is a premiere
and I will be photographed huh you do
your makeup just fine I was like but it
doesn't photograph there is a difference
and I'm giving a budget so I'm gonna
take the money yeah yeah yeah
so he's still like trying to understand
that side of it and then you know so
it's really cute so he gets you know the
hours and all that stuff but the other
stuff he's like that's too much for me
you go do your thing I'll hold your
purse well that's great everyone needs
that yeah exactly that's very sweet okay
we're gonna take one last break when we
get back we have a bunch of Internet
questions for you those have lots of
things they want to know so we'll be
right back with more not too deep is
there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals well better help
online counseling can help they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more they connect you
with professional counselors in a safe
and private online environment you can
get help at your own time at your own
pace
everything you share is confidential
it's so convenient you can schedule
secure video or phone sessions as well
as chat and text with your therapist and
if for some reason you're not happy with
your counselor you can request a new one
at any time for no additional charge
best of all it's affordable and you guys
will get 10% off your first month with
the discount code grace so why not get
started go to better help calm slash
grace and you fill out a questionnaire
that will help them assess your needs
and match you with a counselor that
you're loved that's better help calm
slash grace okay we're gonna get into
these internet questions but before we
do want to ask you the two questions
asked every single guest that's on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti act in cold spaghetti mmm-hmm
that'd be a good or bad thing it's up to
you cold spaghetti yet yeah yeah that's
it that's a pretty pop
answer as if I want it to be very spicy
[Laughter]
I think that's a great answer I can
visualize it in my head okay the other
question is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or close call but you can
only use three words or small phrases so
mine is a college jogging front lawn
okay okay close call mmm
beans day bedtime
sounds like a great thing to me it
sounds really fun no follow up questions
here okay let's get into these questions
from Twitter and Instagram someone to
know if you could time travel where
would you go I would probably go back to
the secret life days really enjoy it
yeah what kind of advice would you give
like your younger self were you so like
nervous about it then you don't feel
like you enjoyed it I think I was
nervous about what was next
oh yeah yeah you know how you have so
many people in your ear being like well
you got to have a plan and you got a mmm
what's after this and this isn't gonna
last forever and not only that but when
you get when you're doing interviews
like you and I right now what are you
working on now yeah and it's like well
I'm not sure mine groaners like way to
expect it's not that easy to get a movie
oh yeah yeah so I and the amount that
you're working like you said you're
working like 15 hour days yes what how
when do you have time to audition for
anything we're doing other work yeah
exactly and then you know we're under
contract there's only so much work we
can do mmm okay I'm so I probably go
back and just tell myself just enjoy
these years and I did I had fun I don't
remember a lot because I was so paranoid
about when it was gonna be over and then
it was over and I didn't know what I was
gonna do mm-hmm yeah and that consumes
you and keeps you from being present
yeah in that moment yeah exactly
I think that's general good advice
across the board to anyone that books
the show I know that there's other
things you want to do and other things
sound so much better but like just enjoy
the time because it only lasts a few
seasons and six years sounds like a lot
10 years sounds like a lot but then it's
over
it flies by I'm sure yeah it flies by
and they become your family yeah
with anyone that's on a show and they're
like I'm over it really enjoy it yeah at
the time because you don't know what
you'll be on the show again yeah that's
so true and I think that's something
that people probably don't can't really
understand that aren't part of this you
know industry like that you're not
guaranteed the jobs that you get no and
so you do live in kind of a little
constant paranoia and fear about what's
next and like trying to balance that and
like be appreciative in the moment of
what you're working on is difficult yeah
and I think I would tell people to just
continue studying like I stopped taking
acting class I was like I'm fine now I
booked a show I'm good yeah and I didn't
realize that I didn't know how to do
anything else but Adrian Oh interesting
which I think is the story of a lot of
people like I had so many habits that I
had developed that when I did go back to
acting class after her uh-huh my acting
coach was like oh you built some habits
we're gonna have to break again you're
not even listening anymore and because I
knew the script so well my stories I
didn't have to listen Wow or dive in or
dig deep or do any of the work that we
have to do in developing a character
mmm-hmm yeah I think that's probably
overlooked
he said interesting um don't know this
might be true deep but how do you feel
about representing Latinas ungrown
--is-- hmm do you get a lot of messages
from people about that sort of thing
yeah and I actually don't even know how
to take that question because I'm
playing a Cuban character and I'm not
Cuban okay uh-huh and that was actually
something that was nervous about when I
first took the role on and I'm very open
about it because all of us are kind of
guilty of pointing that out on an actor
I mean I know when JLo booked Selena the
pitch she's not even Mexican she's
Puerto Rican blah blah blah yeah she did
an amazing job mm-hmm and it doesn't
matter it shouldn't matter and I think
sometimes we can segregate ourselves and
discriminate ourselves when we should
really be united I think it's really
important to me and I'm honored that I
get to play someone that a culture that
I didn't even know about and I've had to
do research on so I know it matters
especially today being latina and really
representing and taking it seriously
like we talked about earlier the
platform that I have yeah and I'm
honored that I'm one of the few that's
like you know getting in that door to
like actually star
in something because it's not easy and
it's not really available to us hmm I
mean it's interesting too because it
sounds like you truly care about it and
it's not someone that's like throwing
away this opportunity or like not
hearing the people that have feedback
about it but instead just offering the
fact that you genuinely care about
representing in the best way that you
possibly can right and it's because I've
never been asked this question before
until recently
mm-hmm when was the first time you saw
yourself on television oh wow and I was
like I know I don't know and I did I
never even realized that someone is when
they see me or when they see Gina
Rodriguez they're seeing themselves oh
it's not just like this or you know I am
normal
right I mean I remember I love to bring
it on but there were no Latinas in there
right and I remember okay Celina
can Keith Ania well no she was a singer
okay there was JLo but okay um some high
okay like I could name three people Wow
now there's more which is great that's
so interesting to an interesting that
you hadn't even thought about it no and
I didn't realize that back then when
people told me you're never gonna make
it was because of that that's because
there weren't people like me on
television interesting yeah wooof that's
really cool and also must be a little
bit of pressure yeah cuz I'm like sugar
I need another job hire me okay a lot of
people are asking about like what was
the best piece of advice Tyra Banks gave
you Wow
she gave me a lot of advice um I turned
30 while I was out there I think she
really was honing in on building your
empire and your brand and she showed me
how she was building hers and how
important it was to really learn it and
be involved in it cuz even believe it or
not she's super plugged into her
Instagram that is her oh yeah no that's
the thing that I find the most
fascinating about following her on
social media is that she I think she
sent me a DM one time from a video that
I did and she said something like come
to set and I'll I'll beat your face for
like a video because I was doing like a
makeup tutorial thing and she's like
even come to my trail
and I was like is this for real yeah
yeah she believes in women she loves
women yeah that's so cool yeah women
empowerment so and I don't even think
she told me that's just watching her and
how humble she is and just genuinely
appreciate the platform she has and
wants to give it to people like I think
that really taught me a lot oh I tell
the story but I forgot about it
um one of our actresses asked a question
we had a designer there and she was like
do you think it and she's young she was
like she's like 13
this entire do you think it'd be
inappropriate if I asked if he would
design my dress for the premiere and
tire was like yeah you know he's here to
work it would be inappropriate but good
for you for asking that question and
coming to me and knowing to ask and not
you know like she turned something that
could have been a downer like I'm
embarrassed I asked into a positive
that's awesome so I learned that from
her to really take negative situations
and find a silver lining to make it
positive that's super cool and also just
like encouraging curiosity mm-hmm that's
very cool she sounds awesome yes I want
her to have another show is her show
still on no top model the her talk show
no no okay well maybe there should be
another one I'm manifesting it right now
what is your favorite self-care tip my
sleep sleep like go home and take a nap
after this if you have time wine and
then sleep oh yeah I am in any order
yeah someone's no did you have to learn
all the chair moves for bring it on yes
we did have to learn all the chair moves
and I was a cheerleader in high school
oh you were mm-hmm oh so you had an
advantage yeah I think was more the
dancing part that gave me an advantage
because we did have a dance audition we
didn't have a cheer audition oh really
yeah
so that gave me a huge advantage oh wow
we were auditioning at the studio that I
was dancing at so it was great
oh by ago yeah we had about we had a few
weeks of rehearsal before we actually
started shooting it was really fun yeah
how was that set um it was my first time
ever on a set oh really I didn't know
anything I didn't know what a mark was
uh-huh I didn't know that we could take
our time after the director says action
okay I don't know how to read a call
sheet
uh-huh
I didn't know anything I didn't know
that you know crafty was as amazing as
it is gained a lot of weight on that
brought us like Roscoe's and Popeyes and
stuff oh dang and there was a scene when
we're doing Shibuya cuz I had eaten so
much and my button literally popped off
in the middle of the dance and they had
to I don't know he was elastic to tie it
back it was bad that's so funny is that
in deleted scenes anywhere No thank God
editor out there that has that clip
somewhere someone's gonna find it now
I'm so curious um a lot of people asking
about what is your greatest personal and
professional accomplishment personal
accomplishment is actually realizing I
needed help and seeking therapy oh cool
that was a big one for me I think that's
really important too like I was talking
to someone about this the other day and
I like normalizing that mm-hmm so I
think people get really afraid to seek
help yeah I guess it's different now for
sure but culturally in the Mexican
culture and I talked to my uncle about
this mhm you don't go to therapy unless
you're considered crazy and you need to
go into an insane asylum oh okay so when
I first really realized that I had to go
and realize what it was and I told my
mom she had a freakout really it's like
well she said in Spanish she's like no
naka like you're not crazy why do you
need to go you're fine uh-uh
I'm like mom like we went through a lot
growing up and you know I suffered a lot
of trauma with this last relationship
like I really have to like figure it out
and it was my acting coach that said I'm
not gonna coach you unless you go really
wow like people really had to intervene
Jeana who's over here it's like been my
best friend since we were 14 we worked
together now but like she came to set
one time I was feeling movie she goes I
need to talk to you you're not okay and
you're we haven't spoken in weeks like
are you okay oh my god fine wow that was
a personal accomplishment I still go and
you know I talk about it now but that
was definitely something big for me and
I've grown a lot from it yeah I think if
you have the means to seek out in any
form of therapy that makes sense for you
I always encourage that mmm-hmm it's
difficult but it's
you know things have to be hard to get
easier yeah exactly yeah yeah just like
I always compare it to storms like what
happens after I saw mm-hmm you know the
Sun comes out the flowers are bright I
mean we just had those rain showers and
we had the greenest mountains ever I
know it was so we lived in the Shire for
a second it was nuts yeah okay last
question they want to know death row
last meal got a nice salad with frijoles
gone [ __ ] the yes Wow you had that
locked and loaded yeah yesterday
that's incredible thank you for being
here making time and talking with us
before you go every guest that's on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie from staring this whole time yeah
sorry we never really bring it up and it
is a weird thing that just linger on
this yeah of course
see what it where's the fortune um it
might be touched
oh it is oh yes I just watched dad to me
have you guys seen that yet no I haven't
seen it yet okay so I'm like a dog
walked by and tooted against your car
this morning before you woke up it's
probably mine it was somehow rate it's
somehow it has somehow raised the value
of your car well I do have a very cute
dog you do I do what kind
he's a terrier mix I'm not sure he's a
rescue oh he's very cute and everyone
wants to pet him but he is afraid of the
world oh okay I even therapy right now
oh good going well okay where can people
find you online if they don't already
know Instagram Twitter Facebook I'm
mostly active on Instagram I promise
I'll try to be better on the other
platforms but it's at francia raisa
awesome and when can people watch Cronus
June 5th we air every Wednesday on free
form at 8 o'clock perfect thank you so
much for being here thank you for
finally fun especially know you're a
wrestling fan oh man I know now I got to
meet them is here you guys need to do a
buddy cop movie well I would not mind
doing another Christmas bounty movie but
you know I would they were filming miz
and miz's
when that's true over at the
gender-reveal so you might see me there
oh I can't wait it's like Where's Waldo
yeah exactly okay guys thanks for
listening and watching we'll see you
next time on another episode of not too
deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
whatever struggles you are facing from
depression and anxiety to trauma and
grief better help can connect you with a
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment it's so
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and anything
you share is completely confidential
best of all it's affordable and our
listeners get 10% off your first month
with the discount code grace so why not
get started go to better help calm slash
grace and fill out a questionnaire to
get matched with a counselor you'll love
today not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer and
edited by melissa demons writing by
diane kang a production assistants by
Katrina Henning post-production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]